chef games on m'a dit que vous avez à
votre actif plus de 600 sauvetage c'est
pour ainsi dire une prouesse harrison
m'a dit que tu partes et quelques jours
avec blake part demain il doit reprendre
la fad la raccompagne n'en reviens pas
qu'elle soit déjà à la fac r go séries à
l'eau tout va bien je voulais faire des
excuses pour la façon dont j'ai réagi
non non et ma mère est ma
cette zone tout entière sera anéantie
vous êtes en train de dire que toute la
faille de san andreas pourrait s'ouvrir
oui c'est très exactement ce que je dis
coviva a abaissé pour moi on ne peut pas
l'arrêter
on ne peut pas s'y préparer ce sera un
phénomène tu
je t'aime pas complexe ne m'abandonne
pas
à baisser vos mots zonal